[موسيقى]
والله وبصراحه فخر مره كبير لنا
وشيء نعتز فيه كلنا يعني شعور جميل
والله كله فخر يعني الله يوفقها ان شاء
الله وترجع للخير البلد ولاهلها والناس
كلهم ان شاء الله هو حدث كبير تاريخي مهم
يحسب لانجازات هذا الوطن الكبير شعورنا
عموما كشعب دائما يملاوي الابتكار احس
بالفخر يعني هذا الشيء اللي راح يصير
صراحه اشعر بالفخر والاعتزاز كوني سعوديه
وان هذا الحدث بيمثل الوطن شيء يعني مشرف
للبلد يعني الحمد لله ازدهار وكل يوم نشوف
حاجه جديده يعني للبلد نحمد الله على ذلك
والى المزيد باذن الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات